the gyro can experience my friend
campaigns went to an Apache reservation
in Arizona I believe last year and he
said that there's actually a cave that
they wind up putting bars on to keep
people from stealing the artifacts but
there's arrows in there and human
remains yeah and they've left them in
there I mean just something like that is
unbelievably fascinating that this
exists and it just exists on this
reservation is sitting there and that
but most people are not even aware of
this is like an unbelievably sacred part
of history that's right there right
right and and those places are
constantly being looted there was a time
in American history 50s 60s 70s where
you could get these beautiful cross
country maps right and many of those
maps would have places where there were
Indian artifacts and places that you
could go and and and and and get stuff
so so a lot of things like that have
been published throughout time and so
folks that are interested in doing that
and make their living doing that you
know they rely on those those old
documents and and stories of where
things are and and are still looting and
and selling those items today I think we
in the West have this idea that if
something is historic we should be able
to look at it you know we should be able
to go to a place the Smithsonian or the
this or that or and go see it mm-hmm
I think what you're saying is we have to
kind of relook at that and that it's not
ours to look at and that this is a part
of the tribes in the part of your
culture and this is not something you
could just gawk at even I mean I've
never even thought about looking at
bones that looking at bones would be
disrespectful until I thought about like
Amy Winehouse is head sitting there at a
museum that I'm like yeah that'd be kind
of [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah that's
is a it's a requires a shift in
perspective right and I think that's all
tribal nations are asking people to do
is to think differently about these
issues and and recreate a new and more
appropriate myth about our collective
history and let us decide for ourselves
what we want to share and what we don't
want to share and I think what you'll
find is is as that Indian nations have
shared a lot so this this work on Native
American graves protection and
repatriation act where those museums
thought they were going to lose all
their collections and their shelves
would be cleaned out and no exhibits
anymore what they found instead was that
they actually figured out what the hell
they've been holding on to this whole
time because now they're actually
talking to the people who who have
experience expertise and cultural
knowledge about these items that are in
their collections so all of a sudden
information that they never had before
and so the relationships that have been
built between museums and those
institutions and tribal nations has has
built something completely different
than nobody had contemplated before just
from talking to native people and in
understanding what those things are and
where they come from and what should be
shared in and what shouldn't be there's
still a lot of museums holding out
though and usually those are the big
well-funded institutions what is their
what's their argument they don't have an
argument what's interesting is is I
wrote somewhere once that you know we're
just waiting for a lot of old white
people to die I mean that's that yeah
that's really the case that there's just
this old perspective this old philosophy
this hoarding philosophy not wanting to
give things back is also in their
defense could it be the
they're really concerned that that stuff
would be lost and that it is yeah
important historical right and so the
the mission of many museums is to
educate the public and there is this
kind of arrogant what I would consider
an arrogant way of thinking about about
the world like everyone should have
access to knowledge and and and tribes
don't necessarily feel that same way I
mean so there is that kind of that
philosophy and so those institutions
will often use the law to work against
the repatriation situation and delay
mostly delay most tribes that want to
fight against institutions like that
because for one thing they don't have
the capacity to fight that because there
are so many things on their table
already and and another reason to bring
that kind of discord around these sacred
items or around ancestral remains is
it's difficult so you don't want to
bring you know bad energy around
something that you need to care for and
respect and and put back in the ground
so you know there's a lot of reasons why
these bigger institutions are getting
away with not following the law hmm and
they take advantage of it and so that's
why my my organization is important
because we try to help bridge that
[Applause]